so am I the only guy that finds that a
little bit odd that this movie is
directed by the same guy who directed
the original red while the sequel to his
film is coming out this weekend in
competition with his new film RIPD it's
a little interesting RIPD or ripped as
I've come to call it stars Ryan Reynolds
Jeff Bridges and Kevin Bacon this movies
about a cop who dies in the line of duty
and is recruited by the rest in peace
department and becomes a partner with
Jeff Bridges these guys basically go
around the world and take out guys who
are actually dead hiding in a human body
their job is to figure out who these
guys are they refer to them as dead O's
and then take them out or at least take
them back to custody so they can
actually go to hell where they belong
they're right off the bat seeing the
trailer for this movie I kept thinking
to myself that's men in black with dead
people that's exactly what it is and
having seen the film now I can confirm
to you that it's men in black with dead
people except the original men in black
film had two great characters a
fantastic script and terrific special
effects for this time this movie has two
characters that are okay a terrible
script and special effects that are so
obvious that it takes you right out of
the movie RIPD is a movie that is all
over the place it's a movie that from
scene to scene may be entertaining you
could sit down and probably not be bored
with this movie but there's just so much
jumbled crap going on that it doesn't
make a cohesive film the director of
this film directed flight plan read Time
Traveler's Wife the guy can make a
good-looking movie and there's an aspect
of this movie that is visually
impressive he does a lot of digital
zooms and zoom out of shots to kind of
make like 15 shots they probably filmed
look like one
there were times in the movie where I
thought wow that was actually a really
cool way of showing that he has an
interesting visual style to him and he
kept the movie moving at least where I
wasn't sitting there wanting to leave
the movie didn't bother me or offend me
it's a perfectly watchable movie it's
just really poorly constructed in the
sense that as you're watching the movie
certain events happen that are really
heavy dramatically and then other events
happen that are so light-hearted that
you can't really feel it like it's
trying to get that same vibe that men in
black had where you could really get
that comedic sense where these two
characters didn't really like each other
and Ryan Reynolds does an okay job but
he's just he's playing Ryan Reynolds I
don't see a character there he basically
feels the same way too
Green Lantern he's playing a sort of
likable guy who pops jokes every once in
a while and has the same sort of
delivery and he it's just what he does
Jeff Bridges is by far my favorite part
of this movie Jeff Bridges plays his
partner he's like this guy from the Old
West he died a long time ago and he
carries a lot of that with him and he
was by far the best part of this movie
Jeff Bridges is one of my favorite
actors another one of my favorite actors
is in this movie as well Kevin Bacon and
he's good for what he has to do until
his entire role is taken over by some
CGI crapfest that's one of the other
things about this movie that I really
did not like was the use of CGI I can't
stand when you make an entire human CGI
I just can't stand it use some makeup
you some prosthetics do something men in
black did that very well where there
were a lot of huge people and they were
makeup they used cgi sparingly actually
in the men in black movies and I was
always really impressed by that this
movie just has CGI all over the place
entire actors are giving performances as
cgi people and you just don't buy it
it's like a giant cartoon the movie
tries to use this comedic element in
which the two guys don't actually look
like themselves Jeff Bridges looks like
this hot bombshell and Ryan Reynolds
looks like an Asian guy it's kind of
funny for a while but then it just gets
old after a while the overuse of CGI
this stupid is all hell script and a
kind of phoned in Ryan Reynolds just
makes this movie very mediocre for me
I'm gonna give ripped a c-minus I don't
really think you need to see this one
out of the - Ryan Reynolds movies that
are coming out this weekend I wouldn't
even see them unfortunately I mean for
Ryan Reynolds honestly like what's going
on with him lately hmm he was in Green
Lantern so guys have you seen RIPD let
me know what you thought of it if you
have did you think it was a men and
black ripoff as always guys thanks for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck man eyes
[Music]